last night the united states
brought the world's number one terrorist
leader to justice
abu bakar al-baghdadi
is dead he was the founder and leader of
isis
the most ruthless and violent terror
organization anywhere in the world
the united states has been searching
for baghdadi for many years
capturing or killing baghdadi has been
the top
national security priority of my
administration
u.s special operations forces executed a
dangerous and daring nighttime raid
in northwestern syria and accomplished
their mission in grand style
the u.s personnel were incredible
i got to watch much of it
no personnel were lost
in the operation while a large number of
baghdadis fighters and companions
were killed with him he died after
running into a dead end tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way
the compound had been cleared by this
time
with people either surrendering or being
shot and killed
eleven young children were moved out of
the house
and are uninjured the only ones
remaining
were baghdadi and the tunnel and he had
dragged
three of his young children with him
they were led to certain death he
reached the end of the tunnel
as our dogs chased him down
he ignited his vest killing himself
and the three children his body
was mutilated by the blast the tunnel
had caved in on it in addition
but test results gave certain
immediate and totally positive
identification it was him
the thug who tried so hard to intimidate
others
spent his last moments in utter fear
in total panic and dread terrified of
the
american forces bearing down on him
we were in the compound for
approximately two hours
and after the mission was accomplished
we took highly sensitive material and
information
from the raid much having to do with
isis
origins future plans
things that we very much want
baghdadi's demise demonstrates america's
relentless pursuit of terrorist leaders
and our commitment to the enduring
and total defeat of isis and other
terrorist organizations
our reach is very long as you know last
month we announced that we recently
killed
hamza bin laden the very violent son of
osama bin laden who was saying very bad
things about people
about our country about the world
he was the heir apparent to al qaeda
terrorists who oppress and murder
innocent people
should never sleep soundly
knowing that we will completely destroy
them
these savage monsters will not escape
their fate
and they will not escape the final
judgment of god
baghdadi has been on the run for many
years
long before i took office
but in my direction as
commander-in-chief of the united states
we obliterated his caliphate 100 percent
in march of this year today's events are
another reminder that we will continue
to pursue
the remaining isis terrorists
to their brutal end that also goes for
other
terrorist organizations they are
likewise in our sights
baghdadi and the losers who worked for
him
and losers they are they had no idea
what they were getting into
in some cases they were very frightened
puppies
in other cases they were hardcore
killers
but they killed many many people
their murder of innocent americans james
foley
stephen shotloff peter kasich
and kayla mueller were especially
heinous the shocking publicized murder
of jordanian pilot
a wonderful young man spoke to the king
of jordan they all knew him they all
loved
he was burned alive in a cage for all to
see
on the execution of christians
in libya and egypt as well as the
genocidal mass murder of yesidis
rank isis among the most depraved
organizations
the history of our world
the forced religious conversions
the orange suits prior to
so many beheadings all of which were
openly displayed for the world to see
this was all that abu
bakr bugatti
this is what he wanted this is what he
was proud of
he was a sick and depraved
man and now he's gone
baghdadi was vicious
and violent and he died in a vicious and
violent way as a coward running
and crying this raid was
impeccable and could only have taken
place with the
acknowledgement and help of certain
other nations and people
i want to thank the nations of russia
turkey
syria and iraq and i also want to thank
the syrian kurds for certain support
they were able to give us
this was a very very dangerous
mission thank you as well to the great
intelligence professionals
who helped make this very successful
journey
possible i want to thank the soldiers
and sailors airmen and
marines involved in last night's
operation
you are the very best there is anywhere
in the world no matter where you go
there is nobody even close
i want to thank general mark milley and
our joint chiefs of staff and i also
want to thank our professionals
who work in other agencies of the united
states government
and were critical to the mission's
unbelievable success
last night was a great night for the
united states
and for the world a brutal killer
one who has caused so much hardship and
death
has violently been eliminated
he will never again harm another
innocent man
woman or child he died like a dog
he died like a coward the world is now
a much safer place
god bless america thank you
any questions this was a operation he's
going to get started
we've had him under surveillance for
a couple of weeks we knew a little bit
about where he was going where he was
heading
we had very good information that he was
going to another location he didn't go
two or three efforts were canceled
because he decided to change his mind
constantly changing his mind
and finally we saw that he was here
held up here we knew something about the
compound we knew it had tunnels
the tunnels were dead end for the most
part
there was one we think that wasn't but
we had that covered too
just in case the level of intelligence
the
level of work was was pretty amazing
when we landed with eight helicopters
a large crew of brilliant fighters
ran out of those helicopters and blew
holes into the side of the
building not wanting to go through the
main door because that was booby-trapped
and there was something there was
something really amazing to see
i got to watch it along with general
milley
vice president pence others uh in the
situation room and we watched it
uh so
well clearly don't want to say how but
we had absolutely perfect as though you
were watching a movie
it was uh that that in the technology
there alone is
is really great uh a big part of the
trip that was
of great danger was the uh it was
approximately an
hour and ten minute flight and we were
flying over
very very uh dangerous territory
in fact uh some of our leaders said that
that could be the most dangerous flying
in and flying out
and that's why last night we were so
quiet about it we didn't say anything
and i didn't make my remark until after
they had landed
safely in a certain area but the the
flight end the flight out
was uh a very very dangerous part there
was a chance that we would have met
unbelievable fire uh
russia treated us great they opened up
we had
fly over certain russia areas russia
held areas
russia was great
iraq was excellent we really had
great cooperation and you have to
understand they didn't know what we
were doing and where we were going
exactly
but the isis fighters
are hated as much by russia and some of
these other countries
as they are by us uh and that's why i
say they should start doing
a lot of the fighting now and they'll be
able to i really believe they'll be able
to yes jennifer
can you see what role the kurds played
in this generally
they gave us not a military role at all
but they gave us some information that
turned out to be helpful
the kurds can you tell us what the role
of turkey might have been
in iraq what was the role of turkey
turkey we dealt with them they know we
were going in
we flew over some territory
they were terrific no problem they were
not problem you know they could start
shooting
and then we will take them out but
a lot of bad things can happen uh plus
it was a very secret mission we flew
very very low
and very very fast but it was a big it
was a very dangerous part of the mission
uh getting in and getting out too equal
we went in identical we took an
identical route
we met with gunfire coming in but it was
local gunfire
that gunfire was immediately terminated
these people are amazing
they had the gunfire terminated
immediately meaning
they were shot from the airships i'm
trying to understand the timing
uh you talked earlier you know several
weeks about pulling troops out
you know and then put that in and you
know i'm trying to understand the timing
of when
this operation well from the first day i
came to office
and now we're getting close to three
years i would say
where's al baghdadi i want al baghdadi
and we would kill terrorist leaders but
they were names i never heard of they
were names that weren't recognizable and
they weren't the big names
some good ones some important ones but
they weren't the big names
i kept saying where's al baghdadi
and a couple of weeks ago they were able
to scope him out you know these people
are very smart they're not
into the use of cell phones anymore
they're not they're very technically
brilliant you know they use the internet
better than almost anybody in the world
perhaps other than donald trump
but they use the internet incredibly
well and what they've done
with the internet through recruiting and
everything and that's why he died like a
dog he died
like a coward he was whimpering
screaming and crying
and frankly i think it's something that
should be brought out
so that his followers and all of these
young kids that want to leave
various countries including the united
states they should see how he died
he didn't die a hero he died a coward
crying
whimpering screaming and bringing three
kids with him
to die certain death and he knew the
tunnel had
no end i mean it was a uh it was a
closed
closed end they call it a closed end
tunnel
not a good place to be what's going on
before
you made the announcement that you're
i've been looking for him for
three years i've been looking for him i
started getting some very positive
feedback about a month ago
and we had some incredible intelligence
officials that did a great job
that's what they should be focused on
and about what time did this operation
start yesterday sir
and have you notified well this
operation started two weeks ago
in terms of the real operation because
we had him scoped
we thought he'd be in a certain location
he was
things started checking out very well uh
we were involved in on our own team with
some brilliant people
who i've gotten to know brilliant people
that love our country
highly intelligent people and uh we
uh we've had it uh pretty well scoped
out for a couple of weeks but
he tends to change immediately he had a
lot of cash
he tends to change like on a dime where
he'll be going to a certain location all
of a sudden he'll go someplace else
and you'll have to cancel but this was
one where
we knew he was there and you can never
be 100
sure because you're basing it on
technology more than anything else
but we thought he was there and then we
got a confirmation
and when we went in uh
they were greeted with a lot of fire
power
a lot of fire power i'll tell you these
guys they do a job
they are so brave and so good and so
importantly
many of his people were killed um
and we'll announce the exact number over
the next uh 24 hours
but many were killed uh we lost nobody
think of that it's incredible when you
told the russians
our dog was hurt actually the canine
was uh hurt went into the tunnel
but we lost nobody you requested the
to the russians to fly over this area
they controlled what did you
spoke to the russians what did you tell
them we told them we're coming in
and they said
thank you for telling us they were very
good but did you tell them why
no no they did not know why
we did tell them we think you're going
to be very happy
because you know again they hate isis as
much as we do
you know what isis has done to russia so
uh no we did not tell they did not know
the mission
but they knew we were going over an area
that they had
uh they had a lot of firepower and have
you notified the congressional leaders
about the pelosi
we've notified some others are being
notified now as i speak
we were going to notify him last night
but we decided not to do that because
washington leaks like i've never seen
before there's nothing
there's no country in the world that
leaks like we do
and washington is a leaking machine and
i told my people we will not notify them
until the our great
people are out not just in but out i
don't want to have them greeted with
uh fire power like you wouldn't believe
so we were able to get in it was top
secret
it was kept there were no leaks no
nothing
the only people that knew were the few
people that i dealt with
and again mark millie and the joint
chiefs of staff were incredible
uh we had some tremendous backup
robert o'brien secretary esper
secretary pompeo
pence i told you he was great we there's
a very small group of people that knew
about this we had very very few people
we
a leak leak could have caused the death
of all of them now
they're so good that i think nothing was
going to stop them anyway you want to
know the truth that's how good they were
we had them also
surrounded by massive air power up in
the air
yesterday surrounded at very high levels
we were very low
we had tremendous air power you watched
all this from the sit room who
were you with in the sit room when you
watched secretary
uh esper a few of the joint chiefs
mark milley uh some generals
we had some very great uh military
people in that room
and we had some great intelligence
people robert o'brien
it's really good yes was the pull out of
the
u.s troops in syria last month
strategically tied aid was
with this raid no no the pull out right
sure it's a great question
and you're doing a great job by the way
your network is fantastic they're really
doing a great job please let them know
um no the the pull-out had nothing to do
with this
in fact we found this out at a similar
time it's a very good question because
we found this out at a similar time no
we're after these leaders and we have
others in sight
very bad ones but this was the big one
this is the biggest one
perhaps that we've ever captured because
this is the one that built isis and
beyond
and was looking to rebuild it again very
very strongly looking to build it again
that's why he went to this province this
way he went to this area you know a lot
of
people i was watching uh this morning
and hearing and they said why was he
there
people were so surprised well that's
where he was trying to rebuild from
because that was the place that made
most sense if you're looking to rebuild
them yeah i said that right after i knew
they had landed safely
when they had returned and that was to
notify you guys that you have
something big this morning so you
wouldn't be out playing golf
or tennis
i'd rather not say but we landed in a
very friendly
port in a friendly country um
give you any pause about your decision
to withdraw no i think it's great
look we don't want to keep
soldiers between syria and turkey
for the next 200 years they've been
fighting for hundreds of years
we're out but we are leaving soldiers to
secure the oil
now we may have to fight for the oil
it's okay maybe somebody else wants eu
which case to have a hell of a fight
but there's massive amounts of oil and
we're securing it for a couple of
reasons number one
it stops isis because isis got
tremendous wealth from that oil we have
taken it
it's secured number two and again
somebody else may claim it
but either we'll negotiate a deal with
whoever is claiming it if we think
it's fair or we will militarily stop
them
very quickly we have tremendous power in
that part
of the world we have uh you know the
airport is right nearby
a very big very monstrous very uh
very powerful airport and very expensive
airport that was built years ago
we're in there for we're in that middle
east now for
8 trillion so we don't want to be
keeping syria and turkey they're going
to have to make their own decision
the kurds have worked along incredibly
with us but in all fairness it was much
easier dealing with the kurds after they
went through three days of fighting
because that was a brutal
three days and if we would have said to
the kurds hey do you mind moving over
seven miles because you know they were
in the middle
mostly so you have seven or eight miles
could you mind
moving over because i have to say turkey
has taken tremendous deaths
from that part of the world you know we
call it a safe zone
but it was anything but a safe zone
turkey has lost thousands and thousands
of people from that safe zone
so they've always wanted that safe zone
for many years i'm glad i was able to
help him get it
but we don't want to be there we want to
be home i want our soldiers home
or fighting something that's meaningful
i'll tell you who loves us
being there russia and china
because while they build their military
we're depleting our military there
so russia loves us being there now
russia likes us being there for
two reasons because we kill isis
we kill terrorists and they're very
close to russia
we're 8 000 miles away now maybe they
can get here but we've done very well
with homeland security and the ban
which by the way is approved by the
united states supreme court as you know
you know there was a reporter that said
we lost the case and he was right in the
early court he refused he didn't want to
say just refuse to say
that we won the case in the supreme
court so you know but we have a very
effective ban
and it's very hard for people to come to
our country but it's many
thousands of miles away whereas russia's
right there turkey's right there
syria is there they're all right there
excuse me iran
is right there iraq is right there they
all hate isis
so we don't you know in theory they
should do something
i'll give you something else the
european nations have been a tremendous
disappointment
because i personally called but my
people called a lot
take your isis fighters and they didn't
want them
they said we don't want them they came
from france they came from germany they
came from the uk
they came from a lot of countries and i
actually said to them you don't take
them i'm going to drop them right on
your border and you can have fun
capturing them again
but the united states taxpayer is not
going to pay for the next 50 years
you see what guantanamo costs we're not
going to pay tens of billions of dollars
because we were good enough to capture
people that want to go back to germany
france uk and other parts of europe
and they can walk back they can't walk
to our country
we have lots of water in between our
country and
them so yeah go you mentioned that you'd
met some
gotten to know some brilliant people
along this process who had helped
provide information and and and advice
along the way
is there any one in particular or would
you like to give anyone credit for
getting to this point today well i i
would but if i mentioned one i have to
mention so many i spoke to senator
richard burr this morning
and as you know he's very involved with
intelligence and the committee
and he's a great gentleman uh i spoke
with lindsey graham just a little while
ago in fact lindsey graham is right over
here
and he's been very much involved in this
subject and he's
he's a very strong hawk but i think
lindsay agrees with what we're doing now
and again there are plenty of other
countries that can help them patrol i
don't want to leave
a thousand or two thousand to three
thousand soldiers on the
border but where lindsay and i
totally agree is the oil the oil is uh
you know so valuable for many reasons
it fueled isis number one
number two it helps the kurds
because it's basically been taken away
from the kurds they
were able to live with that oil and
number three it can help us because we
should be able to take some also
and what i intend to do perhaps is make
a deal with
an exxon mobil or one of our great
companies to go in there and
do it properly right now it's not big
it's big oil underground but it's not
big oil
up top much of the machinery has been
shot and dead
it's been through wars but uh and
and spread out the wealth but no we're
protecting the oil
we're securing the oil now that doesn't
mean we don't make a deal at some point
but i don't want to be there they're
fighting for a thousand years they're
fighting for centuries
i want to bring our soldiers back home
but i do want to secure the oil if you
read about the history of donald trump i
was a civilian
i had absolutely nothing to do with
going into
iraq and i was totally against it but i
always used to say if they're going to
go in
nobody cared that much but it got
written about if they're going to go in
i'm sure you've heard the statement
because i met him when any human being
alive
if they're going into iraq keep the oil
they never did they never did i know
lindsey graham had a bill where
basically we would have been paid back
for all of the billions of dollars that
we've spent
many many billions of dollars and i hate
to say it it's actually trillions of
dollars but many many billions of
dollars
and uh by one vote they were unable to
get that approved in the senate they had
some
pretty big opposition from people that
shouldn't have opposed like a president
and they weren't able if you did that
iraq would be a much different story
today because they would be
owing us a lot of money they would be
treating us much differently but i will
say iraq was very good with respect to
the raid last night
just to pin down the timing a little bit
better here you got back to the white
house around 4
30 yesterday afternoon did you
immediately go to the situation
well i knew all about this for three
days yesterday yeah we thought for three
days this is what was going to happen
it was actually look nobody was even
hurt
our canine as they call i call it a dog
a beautiful dog a talented dog
was injured and brought back
but uh we had no soldier injured and
they did a lot of shooting and they did
a lot of blasting
even not going through the front door
you know you think you go through the
door
if you're a normal person you say knock
knock may i come in the fact is that
they blasted their way into
the house in a very heavy wall and it
took them
literally seconds by the time those
things went off they had a beautiful big
hole and they ran and they got everybody
by
surprise unbelievably brilliant as
fighters
i don't i can't imagine there could be
anybody better and these as you know are
our top
operations people
was there any indication of that well we
don't know that
but he was the last one out and his
people had either been killed
which there were many or gave up
and came out because with the 11
children that came out we were able to
do that uh we don't know if they were
his children they might have been
but as i said three died in the tunnel
and the tunnel collapsed
with the explosion but but you had other
fighters coming out also
and they're being brought back uh
they're being they're right now
we have them imprisoned as children they
were but do you remember what
time you went into the situation room
well i started at five o'clock
we were pretty much gathered at five
o'clock yesterday
we were in contact all day long through
hopefully secure phones i'll let you
know tomorrow but nothing seemed to leak
so i guess they were secure for a change
uh but uh we gathered
more or less at five uh the attack
started moments after that the the
liftoff started moments after that again
the the element of attack that they were
most afraid of was getting from
our base into that compound because this
tremendous firepower that we were
you know flying over uh
and i won't go into it but you had a
very big russian
presence in one area you had a turkish
presence you had
a syrian presence and you're flying low
it's very dangerous and there were shots
made but we think these were people that
were shooting that were
indiscriminately shooting the
helicopters took some shots but
we think that these were people that
were just random people that
don't like to see helicopters i guess
is there any kind of dna test done so
that's another part of the genius of
these people they brought his they have
his dna
more of it than they want even and they
brought it with them
with lab technicians who were with them
and they assumed that this was baghdadi
they thought visually it was him
but they assumed it was him and they did
a site
an on-site test they got samples
and to get to his body they had to
remove a lot of debris because the
tunnel had collapsed but these people
are
very good at that and uh and they as i
said they brought body parts back with
them etc it said there wasn't much left
the uh
the uh the vest blew up but uh there are
still substantial pieces that that
they brought back so they did an on-site
test because we had to know this
and it was a very quick call that took
place
about 15 minutes after he was killed
and it was positive it was it's
this is a confirmation sir
there was also a report that his wife
had done
or one of his wives who detonated it so
there are two women
there were two women both
wives both wearing vests
they had not detonated but the fact that
they were dead and they had vests on
made it very difficult
for our men because they had vests on
and it made it very difficult for our
men
because you never know what's going to
happen they're lying they're dead they
never detonated
but they were dead on the successor the
possible successors have you been
briefed on who
yeah we know these successors and we've
already got them in our sites and we'll
tell you
uh that right now but we know the
successors
uh hamsa bin laden was a big thing
but this is the biggest there is this is
uh
the worst ever uh osama bin laden was
very big but osama bin laden became big
with the world trade center this is a
man who built a hole
as he would like to call it a country a
caliphate
and was trying to do it again
and i had not heard too much about his
health i've heard stories about he may
not have been in good health
but he died he died in a a ruthless
vicious manner that i can tell you with
any adults
yes we have people that were taken we
have
uh many of the people died on the site
but we have people that were taken yes
and and the children uh we are we left
them under care of
somebody that we understand
do you believe that 11 children 11
children how many adults
i'd rather not say i'd leave that to the
generals but a small group
uh more dead than alive
which operation teams were involved
which special operations teams were
involved
many of them and at the top level
and people that were truly incredible at
their craft i've never seen anything
like it
as far as partnerships goes were there
any other
forces involved or was this only
american tradition only american forces
only american forces but we were given
great cooperation did the u.s rely
we told the russians were coming in
because we had to go over them
and they were curious but
but uh we said we're coming we're right
now we said one way
you look we're coming but they were very
cooperative they really
were good and we did say it would be a
mission that they'd like too because you
know again they hate isis as much as we
do
and then for intel purposes was learning
was there any foreign intel that proved
useful along the way
uh in this operation so
we had our own intel we got
very little help we didn't need very
much help we have some
incredible people when we use our
intelligence correctly
what we can do is incredible when we
waste our time with intelligence
that hurts our country because we had
poor leadership at the top
that's not good but i've gotten to know
many of the intel people and i will say
that they are
spectacular now they're not going to
want to talk about it they want to keep
it quiet
the last thing they want because these
are these are
great patriots but the people that i've
been dealing with are incredible people
and it's really a deserving name
intelligence i've dealt with some people
that aren't very intelligent
having to do with intel but this is the
top people and it was incredible
it was flawless and it was very
complicated
but so i do appreciate russia
turkey iraq and syria to an extent
because
uh you know we're flying into syria a
lot of
syrian people with lots of guns
so we had uh good cover for
probably the most dangerous part it
would not sound to you know when you fly
in it doesn't sound like that would be
the most dangerous when you're going
into shooting nests and
all of the things that happened once
they broke into that pretty powerful
compound that was a very strong compound
and as i said had tunnels but
the most dangerous part we had great
cooperation with yesterday
did you inform speaker pelosi ahead of
time
no i didn't i didn't i didn't do that i
wanted to make sure this kept
secret i don't want to have men lost and
women
uh i don't want to have people lost
would you anticipate
um inviting the special forces teams to
the white house
oh yeah they'll be invited i don't know
if they'll want to have
their faces shown to be honest with you
you know they want to
they're incredible for the country
they're not looking for public relations
but uh they love doing what they're
doing
i've seen it first lady was out there
recently looking at what they do she
came back she said
wow i've never seen anything like that
the training you know all of the
training and
and the power of the people uh the men
and women the strength the physical
strength the mental strength these are
incredible people these are very unique
individuals
could you hear that on your video hookup
pitch in the whimpering of
back daddy i don't want to talk about it
but
uh he was screaming crying
and whimpering and
he was scared out of his mind
and think of james foley
think of kayla think of the things he
did to kayla
what he did to foley and so many others
and for those people that say oh isn't
this a little violent
think of how many times have you seen
men
i think in all cases men for the most
part but
in terms of this where you see the
orange suits
and you see the ocean and they're
beheaded
or how many of you got to see because it
was out there
the jordanian pilot whose plane went
down they captured him they put him in a
cage and they set him on fire
and the king of jordan actually attacked
very
powerfully when that happened they've
never seen a thing like that
but he set him on fire this was al
baghdadi
and uh you should never ever hopefully
see a thing like that again now
there'll be new people emerge but this
was the worst
of of this particular world this was the
worst probably in certain ways the
smartest
he was also a coward and he didn't want
to die
but think of it everybody was out and we
were able to search him down and find
him in the tunnel we knew the tunnel
existed
and that's where he was i mean i'll tell
you a story in iraq
so they spent president bush went in
i strongly disagreed with it even though
it wasn't my expertise at the time but i
had a i have a very good instinct about
things
they went in and i said that's a
tremendous mistake
and there were no weapons of mass
destruction it turned out i was right
i was right for other reasons but it
turned out
on top of everything else they had no
weapons of mass destruction
because that would be a reason to go in
but they had none
but i heard recently that iraq
over the last number of years actually
discriminates against america
in oil leases in other words
some oil companies from other countries
after all we've done have an advantage
in iraq
for the oil i said keep the oil give
them what they need keep the oil
why should we we go in we lose
thousands of lives spend trillions of
dollars
and our companies don't even have an
advantage in getting
the oil leases so i just tell you that
story that's what i heard
uh did gina haspel play a role in this
can you talk a little bit about that and
i saw your
nsc counterterrorism director out in the
hallway was there a role with nfc
yes everybody gina was great everybody
played a role
joe was great gina was great they were
all great just to follow up did your
syria pull out did that generate the
intelligence that led to this operation
no uh we were looking at this
look as i said steve i've been looking
at this i'm here almost three years i've
been looking at this for three years
they'd come in sir we have somebody
under i said i don't want somebody
i want al baghdadi that's the one i want
they say well we have somebody else i
said that's great fine
take them out but i want it al baghdadi
that's who i want i don't want other
people
and then i also wanted hamza
bin laden because he's a young
man around 30 looks just like his father
tall very handsome and he was talking
bad things just like his father
you know if you read my book there was a
book just before the world trade center
came down
and i don't get any credit for this but
that's okay i never do
but here we are um i wrote a book
a really very successful book and in
that book
about a year before the world trade
center was blown up i said
there is somebody named osama bin laden
you better kill him or take him out
something to that effect he's big
trouble
now i wasn't in government i was
building buildings and doing what i did
but i always found it fascinating but i
saw this man
tall handsome very
charismatic making horrible statements
about
wanting to destroy our country and i'm
writing a book
i think i wrote 12 books all did very
well
and i'm writing a book world trade
center had not come down
i think it was about if you check it was
about a year before the world trade
center came down
and i'm saying to people take out osama
bin laden that nobody ever heard of
nobody ever heard of i mean al-baghdadi
everybody hears because he's built this
monster for a long time but nobody ever
heard of
osama bin laden until really the world
trade center
but about a year you'll have to check it
a year year and a half before the world
trade center came
the book came out i was talking about
osama bin laden i said you have to kill
them you have to take them out
nobody listened to me and
to this day i get people coming up to me
they said you know what one of the most
amazing things i've ever seen about you
is that you predicted that osama bin
laden
had to be killed before he knocked down
the world trade center
it's true now most of the press doesn't
want to write that but
you know but it is true if you go back
look at my book i think it was the
america we deserve
uh i i made a prediction and i i
let's put it this way if they would have
listened to me uh a lot of things would
have been different
talk about some of the difficult
decisions you had along the way here
uh in this operation with anything that
weighed on you or that you had
well just death i mean you know i'm
sending a
large number of brilliant fighters
these are the greatest fighters in the
world
uh i'd rather let the generals tell you
but a large number
we had eight helicopters and we had many
other
ships and planes
it was a large group and again
this is a large group heading over very
very strong
firepower areas where
that was decision one will they make it
and they made it but they took fire
but they made it they didn't take we
don't believe again it was nation fire
we believe it was individual group fire
or
gang fire as they call it so they made
it
so that was a big relief then they went
in they blasted their way in
you've heard they blasted their way in
so quickly it was incredible because
this
building was quite powerful strong
they blasted their way in and then all
hell broke loose
it's incredible that nobody was killed
or hurt we had nobody even hurt
and that's why the dog was so great we
actually had a robot
to go in the tunnel but we didn't
get it because we were tracking him very
closely but we had a robot just in case
because we were afraid he had a suicide
vest on and if you get close to him and
he blows it up you're going to
die you're going to die he had a very
powerful suicide first
decisions in the moment while troops are
on the ground no they had it
just incredible we were getting full
reports
on literally a by minute basis
sir we just broke in sir the wall is
down sir you know we've captured sir
two people are coming out right now
hands up fighters
then the 11 children out
numerous people were dead within the
building that they killed
then it turned out they they gave us a
report
sir there's only one person in the
building we are sure he's in the tunnel
trying to escape but it's a dead end
tunnel
and it was brutal
but it was over and as i said when he
blew himself
up the tunnel collapsed on top of him on
top of everything and his children i
mean
so he led his three children to death so
you know in the tunnel that's when um
the robot followed him into that's why
robot was said to but we didn't uh hook
it up because we were too
they were moving too fast we were moving
fast
we weren't a hundred percent sure about
the
tunnel being dead ended it's possible
that there could have been an escape
patch
somewhere along that we didn't know
about
so we moved very very quickly i mean
these people they were moving
they were chasing yeah they were chasing
but again because the suicide vest you
can't get too close
again one of the reasons with the wives
is
if they have a suicide vest you know we
have to be very
very careful these vests are brutal
brutal and they go for
a long distance yes please have you
spoken or will you speak to the families
like the foley family
i'm calling the families now it will be
a pleasure to do that
the foley family who i know uh will be
calling kayla's family uh what what he
did to her was incredible it's a
well-known story and i'm not gonna say
it but you know that he kept her in
captivity for a long period of time
he kept her in his captivity his
personal captivity
she was a beautiful woman beautiful
young woman
helped people she was there to help
people
and he saw her
and he thought she was beautiful and he
brought her into captivity for a long
period of time and then he killed her
he was an animal and he was a gutless
animal
thank you all very much i appreciate it
very great day for our country